good afternoon we are now
live good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
my name is Yan Shindler and I'm board
member of the ftth council and I would
like to welcome you to our webinar
hosted by the ftth council
Europe about upgrade without overbuild
via asset reuse expand your network and
not your
footprint before we start with the
webinar let me just quickly highlight a
couple of points about the fth
council we are European industry
Association founded back in
2004 our mission is to Advance ubulus
full fiber based connectivity to the
whole of Europe to all citizens we are
about 164 member companies from various
sectors from vendors operators investors
our activities include expert advises to
policy makers and
Regulators preparing studies and
reports providing Network platform and
of course our annual Flagship the ftth
conference we do a series of fiber
industry webinars providing focused
audience of Industry Specialists and
stakeholders
and of course promote our highly
respected industry
associations and now just some practical
information our webinar will be recorded
and accessible digitally after Vis
session given we have received your
consent you will be notified about
future ftth Council your webinar series
events and if you have questions you can
post your question questions in the
platform where you can find the
questionary and we will try to answer
then maybe at the end of the of all the
sessions at the end of the presentations
or we will do it in written form later
and now let me start and introduce our
sessions and our speakers our topic is
use assets to reuse strategies that
unlock new space in existing Telos and
public sector ducts we will speak about
fiber deployment methods that overbuild
an accelerate time to
Market we will also speak about optical
cable innovations that deliver
unprecedented fiber density and network
infrastructure products that eliminate
emissions and increase
circularity with no compromises on
quality before we start let me just
highlight our greatest challenges from
today's Times
we will need to solve the energy
transition from fossils to Fuels to
renewable sources we need to tackle the
electrification of our
society enabling the application of
electrical power for the world and
something what concerns us with
digitalization of our world channeling
and transporting the explosion of Big
Data just one example you see here on
the slides where where I used the glob
mobile network data traffic as a
highlight increased to
2028 which actually uh shows you a
tramatic explosion of data but not to
forget with that explosion you see
also the explosion of the energy
consumption for this data transmission
you see from 2015 to 2021 a change of
plus to
60% on this uh on this uh transition of
uh
energy and now let me just highlight
what also concerns us nowadays
understanding carbon
emissions carbon emissions we we can
influence in scope one it comes from our
own operation it's controlled by
ourselves emission two comes from
indirect emissions where we for example
purchased electricity steam heating or
cooling from our own
use and scope
three is emission that occurs upstream
and downstream in the value chain and we
here we have the least influence on it
and now let me just ask you a questions
we prepared a poll where you can answer
right now what do you think is a typical
percentage of a telecommunication
operator emissions in scope one do you
think it's less than
10% scope two less than 20% or scope
through is above 70 up to
98% I will launch it right now and then
you will see it and be I will give you
time to answer it in the next 30 seconds
and then I will close it and see what
make actually sense uh from a
telecommunication
perspective I will give it two more
minutes and then we will also see the
answer already and you will see in a
minute that
maybe most of you or basically all of
you have been right so I will close it
right
now and then I will share
the
outcome and as a matter of
fact you see it right
now if I go back to my
presentation
that all of you have been right so on
scope one we
see that less than 10% is come directly
from our operations
about 20% is coming from a the
generation and purchased energy but the
most issue is on scope three where we
have the last at least inflence that up
to 70% could be up to
89% comes from that scope free where we
have basically no
influence now also very quickly
highlight uh that some of our compan
companies have already some uh long-term
and near-term Targets on co2 emission on
scope one and scope two you see it on
the left side from obia the mar company
of dor line or from prisman itself where
we have a clear path and our commitment
to get to Net Zero until
2050 and I believe uh all our uh
stakeholders in our industry should go
in the same direction and we will see at
the end of our webinar why it will be
even more important than we think but
nevertheless let's now introduce our
speakers let's speak about our
challenges we spoke about the limited
space for in we will speak about the The
Limited space for
installation that is limited resources
so cost time and Workforce is not the
only issue but also sustainability will
be a big concern and will be Rel related
to it and with that we will have the
same performance and the same
installation efficiency with that let me
introduce our first Speaker Matthew
Ganon who is global application
marketing manager of D line Matthew the
floor is
yours thank you
[Music]
Yan can you just confirm you guys can
see my screen
y okay
cool well yeah thank you Yan um as Yan
said my name is Matthew gynan and I work
in marketing at jur line and we are the
world's largest manufacturer of micro
ducts for telecoms networks um and what
I want to think about is how we actually
go about doing this thing that it says
on screen so expanding your network and
not your
footprint and from our perspective um
the answer is actually with a couple of
of simple changes with regards to that
underlying physical infrastructure of
the network um the first change is is
what we deploy in terms of um our
product use if we're thinking about
that's those things that contribute to
the scope three emissions of a telecom
Network um so first of all in terms of
reusing to reduce we can reuse existing
materials so this is about increase in
circularity in the supply chain in order
to limit the impacts of the components
that we're putting into the network um
and I'll talk a little bit about how
we're doing that Dural line um with
micro ducts made from reworked materials
and then these can be deployed in
conjunction with smaller fiber cables as
well that reuse fewer raw materials um
to kind of reduce that from a solution
perspective and Adrian from prian will
talk about that after
me and then the kind of secondary use
strategy is to reuse existing assets so
that means um those outsourced
activities in that scope three bucket um
revitalizing existing duct that we've
already got in our Network and avoid the
cost time and disruption of new Civil
Works um and I'll talk about a method
called an O A microduct override which
allows us to do that whereby we install
micro ducts alongside existing cables um
and that gives you a simple cost
effective lowrisk um capacity upgrade
and it's also very low impact
environmentally as
well so first of all let's think about
this concept of circularity and and talk
about how we are increasing that
circularity in the micro supply chain um
so at jaline we take high quality resins
from external sources and turn those
into highdensity polyethylene
pellets those pellets are heated and
extruded and um they're extruded into
individual micro
ducts which we then combine into bundles
and that's what goes into the network um
so this is a simplified um approach
but what happens is there is always
routine Fallout from any manufacturing
process uh and in the Extrusion process
that's a little bit of Fallout
highdensity
polyethylene and what we can do because
we're taking high quality sources um is
we can be sure of the quality of that um
rework material we can turn that back
into pellets and make that into rework
micro duct that can then be installed in
live networks um and the benefit of this
is that um it yields a 50 X reduction in
the carbon emissions compared to those
equivalent um Regular microct products
and none of that waste is actually going
to
landfill so now let's think a little bit
more about this idea of of asset reuse
our second concept and how we can put
these microbs to work um to really allow
you to do that thing that expand your
network without increase in your
environmental
footprint so we'll probably if you
attended any conferences in the last
couple of years you'll have heard this
phrase asset reuse over and over um so
let's think about what's driving that so
first of all um the densification of
existing links perhaps because of
upgrades to new technologies like 5G and
full fiber to the home um you might just
have to do some maintenance on your
existing network if it's been in place
for quite a while um but increasingly um
we're starting to see a lot of
organizations realizing they might have
spare capacity underground that they
might be able to put to work um and
Lease out as
well so the benefits here is you avoid
new civils permitting and overbuild that
accelerates your overall deployment um
it can help minimize your environmental
impact and then um unlock potentially
some new revenue streams as well either
in public or private sector
assets so how might we actually go about
doing this um so let's imagine our
challenge is to to add new fiber on an
existing route but we want to avoid um
all of the things associated with new
construction so if we imagine we've got
a kind of standard 40 33 millimeter duct
um 40 being the outer diameter and 33
being the inner diameter um kind of
common place here in Europe with a 144
fiber loose tube cable with an outer
diameter of 16 mm um it's worth saying
that we always say that cable overlays
can actually damage the new and the
existing cable um and it's therefore not
recommended from kind of a safety
perspective um but it does happen uh so
if you were to do this you would get a
total fiber count of 288 and a capacity
increase therefore of of
2x but you can kind of avoid all of
those concerns regarding the safety of
the installation but also get a much
higher fiber count if you take the
second option which would be a micro
duct override so in the same duct with
the same 16 mil cable uh in place what
you can instead install is two 1210 mm
microducts 12 on the outer diameter turn
on the inner
diameter and now with the advances in um
cable technology which Adrian's going to
talk about you can actually get 864
fibers into each of those microps giving
you a total fiber count of over 1,800
fibers which is a capacity increase of
uh 13x without having to break ground uh
at all
and overrides really are a particularly
versatile upgrade solution so the number
and size of micro looks um that you
install in an override really depends on
your fiber account requirements and your
routing requirements as well um so on
the left hand side let's imagine we're
in a dense Urban location lots of
connections to make distributed
locations for that reason we might
install um smaller micro ducts in in
greater numbers to get more Pathways so
we see 5 12 10 on the
left but if we are um let's say we're
installing Backle fiber um we might
instead install fewer larger Pathways to
accommodate cables with higher overall
fiber counts um so you see three 16 13s
on the right um but it's crucial to note
that the key in both scenarios is to
install all of those micro ducts um
after the same time rather than going
one by one um and then D at the end from
plz talk a little bit more about why
that might be uh
necessary so how might we go about um
doing an override or rather installing
micro ducts into an existing Network
whether that is an empty duct or whether
it has a cable in place so um there are
two main methods um the first is
mechanical insertion and that entails
either pulling or roding in both cases
that um involves feeding something
through the doct
either a rope or a um a rod and then
pulling those micro back um through the
condurat so that you can install your
micro
cables and then the second method is air
jetting U which you can use to install
micr ducts and cables themselves quicker
and over longer distances and the
appropriate method uh and the choice
between these methods um is determined
by the size material and length of the
existing conjur that you already have
place and we can um kind of visualize
that choice um through quite a handy
little um decision
tree so the first consideration is our
material of that existing duct so we've
that made of um PVC transite or
terracotta um which are kind of Legacy
materials that you might find in place
um these are going to be kind of more
prone to cracking uh meaning they'll be
harder to pressurize with high-speed air
uh so you're going to want to use the
mechanical insertion methods here of
pulling or rubbing but on the other side
if you have a duct in place that is made
of HDPE then you going to be able to use
the mechanical insertion methods but
you're more likely to be able to airet
as well um because it's more likely
you'll be able to pressurize that duct
for
jetting the determining Factor then is
the inner diameter of that existing duct
so if it is bigger than 50 mil um you're
going to want to pull or rod
and then if it is lower that's when we
can start to pressurize those um ducts
and jetting becomes a
consideration however if you go in short
distances and your Chambers are say less
than 300 meters apart with the setup
time for jetting then you might just
want to use the mechanical insertion
methods um to complete these short
installations but then really if it's
over 300 MERS that's where jettin really
comes into its own um and that's where
you're going to want to be uh using that
high speeder to install your mic mic
ducts so a little summary of those um
options so pulling chamber space in less
than 300 meters good installation speed
the well established method this uh for
short distances in all the
structures alternatively the second
mechanical insertion method is roding
which gives you an improvement in speed
um so faster installs over shorter
distances and then um jetting so that's
in terms of speed is the best option and
it's going to give you longer distances
at higher speeds and it's also um the
most appropriate method for overrides as
well so in my final section just some
technical considerations and best
practices for working with micro ducts
and completing
overrides so first of all um we've got
two critical calculations for what we
call fill ratio um and that fill ratio
just means how we're filling either the
existing duct or how we're filling the
individual micro ducts um and the first
calculation is for overrides and it uses
cross-sectional area to determine the
appropriate number and size of micro
ducts that we want to install into that
occupied duct so it might sound um
complicated I personally haven't used pi
r squ since I was at high school I don't
think um but that's what we're using
here so we take the area of the existing
cables the area of the additional micro
ducts you want to inst stall and then
divide that by the inner area of the
existing duct multiply that by 100 and
that fill ratio um should not exceed 55%
if it doesn't then your micro ducts are
going to uh fit and you're going to be
able to do that
override and then with your micro ducts
in place um we then need to determine
the right micro cable to install into
that micro duct and to do that we take
the outer diameter of the proposed cable
divide that by the inner diameter of the
microduct you have in place and then
multiply by 100 and as long as that
figure is between 50 and
75% then um that's your optimal fill
ratio range which is going to give you
the best possible Jing performance in
terms of um the air that is going to
carry that cable through the micro do
and fortunately you don't have to
remember these things and do them on the
back of an envelope or the back of your
hand when you're out in the field if you
do go to Jin's website we've got some um
really handy calculators that will do
these calculations for you really really
quickly um you just have to plug in your
own kind of installation parameters and
the cables that you're using um and
it'll help you decide what to install
and
H next consideration um and again DAV
from Plumas I'll talk a little bit more
about this but it's the Y block or the Y
connector so this is a specific piece of
um operatus that is used for an override
so what you see here is let's let's
imagine our jessing machine is over on
the right the micro ducts are being fed
through a feeder tube into the existing
duct on the left and what you see above
here is the existing cable um and what
this piece of equipment allows us to do
is um isolate that cable meaning the
existing duct can be pressurized in
order for these um micro ducts to be
installed so a really powerful piece of
equipment um specifically for an
override and then finally in terms of
actually working with the micro ducts
three best practices is to always
inflate your micro ducts before you jet
them in to give them anti-buckling
stiffness uh and resistance against
crushing whenever you need to connect
individual sections of micro ducts um it
should go without saying but always make
a clean straight cut with appropriate
Cutters and make sure that you're always
using um couplers for that are
appropriate for your microct sizes
and then before you go ahead and do that
cable installation pressurize the entire
route to make sure any sections that you
have coupled or airtight and then um jet
a BB through the system uh before you
lubricate the system to rule out any
kinks or blockages in the way um so that
you're going to get the best possible
cable
installation so in summary hopefully uh
what we've learned is how uh micro
technology can unlock new space in our
existing Network to accelerate our FIB
of the home projects lower those
deployment costs open up new revenue
streams and um as we're talking about
today and it's becoming increasingly
important reduce that overall
environmental impact of the installation
as
well thank you very much I don't know if
we have time for questions now or we
want to keep them to the endm but over
over to
you thanks Matthew for very interesting
presentation now uh Adrian loading up
his presentation let me quickly
introduce him Adrian Muka who Global
Technical sales director of prisman will
now
present his uh presentations on fiber
density and being more sustainable
Adrian back to you thank you Jan for the
introduction can you see my
screen yes yes so thank thanks everyone
for joining this is a continuation of
what Matthew presented so now we are
going to look into the optical
Innovation The Innovation that we are
doing in prism in terms of fiber
Innovation and cable Innovation to reach
unprecedented fiber density to support
the increase in demand in bandwidth and
to be able to create a more
sustainable Optical
infrastructure so one of the key
enablers to create more Innovative and
higher density optical cables have been
the Advent of reduced diameter fibers
especially Ving sensitive fibers that
started in 2006 then as we move to the
need of having higher density cables
there was the introduction of reduced
diameter fiber 200 Micron fiber in 2010
more or less these type of fibers have
the same clading diameter so the same
glass diameter of 125 what we do is
reduce the coating diameter to make it
smaller 30% smaller and in this way we
are able to densify the network and then
in 200
2019 there was introduction of 180
Micron fiber again with the same idea in
mind to be able to increase the fiber
density and support Demand with grow in
demand a 180 Micron fiber is 50% smaller
than the standard 250 Micron and that
way the cables can be made with higher
fiber counts in the same diameter in
order to to be able to Cable an optical
fiber with a smaller diameter is very
important to look at two aspects first
is the glass the glass has to be
designed in order to support a to to be
resistant to macro and micro bending
these are two effects that are very
important when we design a cable
and the coating has to be optimized to
also to reduce the micro vending effects
so here in this plot what you see is a
g65 7 A2 200 Micron fiber with a very
optimized glass and very optimized
coating and you can see that the micro
bending effect is very low so especially
at longer wance at 1550 1625 the micro
bending loss is lower and this allows to
create very high density cables why
microing is important because micro
bending is very is related to the stress
that is applying into the fiber and when
the fibers are put are packaged in a
very compact Cable Construction the
attenuation will increase because of the
compression of the Plastics and the
compression of other fibers to the FIB
that are
there if we look at some other fiber
like for example we don't not optimize
coating and not optimized glass
construction then the attenuation can be
higher and then is more difficult to
make very high density cables that have
the
862 864 fibers for example in 8
mm then another enabler of high density
cables is the optimization of the loose
tubes here I want to show a bit of a bit
of history of loose Tube Technology so
very old cables from the '90s that are
are very old but they they are very good
cables they are probably still working a
lot of kilometers of these cables in
Europe and in 1990 the loose tube
diameter was about 2.5 mm with 12
fibers these cables were these tubes
were made of PBT then in in early 2000
there was a significant Improvement
going down to
1.9 then more or less in 2004 2005 there
was another big jump going to 1.6 mm
tubes with PBT with 250 Micron fibers
then in 200
2013 there was the the the the 200
Micron reduced diameter fiber start
being utilized in loose tube cables and
you can see here that it's possible to
reach it was possible to reach at that
time 1.3
millimeter loose tubes with 12
fibers four micro do
installation then in
2020 more or less 2019 there was the
introduction of a new type of materials
more optimized PBT material that allows
to make very small very
compact L tube loose tube loose tubes
with about one 1.1 mm for 12 fibers then
with the introduction of 180 Micron
fiber in 2019 2020 it it was possible to
develop loose tube loose tubes with 12
fibers and only 0.9 mm you can see here
that there is not a lot of space left
for the fibers to move so that's why
micr bending is very important when we
design this type of
cables these are some examples of
advanced high density Cable Systems that
are available now and that can be used
in fiber to the home deployment so or
data center interconnect Network any
type of network that re requires high
density and there are different
depending on the on the application and
the type of network there can be
different solutions for example the
micro doct cables are for installation
in micro do this offer the highest fiber
density in the market then the ribon
cables they have they have the advantage
of having a mass Fusion splicing for
fast repair time and
faster installation Flex tube cable
these type of cables are very easy to
handle they are very very compact they
have very high fiber counts and can be
installed quite fast then for some some
type of cases where there are some River
Crossing or lakes especially in the
north of Europe then is also we have
also developed some soaka cables with
extreme fiber count like 1,000 fibers in
a sub Aqua cable with all all of this
type of different solution is possible
to enable the high band Network that is
needed for the new applications and for
the new trends in in Optical
communication we are trying to support
our customers to maximize the
utilization of existing infrastructure
as Matthew said is very important to
reuse as much as we can the existing
civil infrastructure to reduce the total
cost of hit of the the of the network
and obviously to reduce the carbon
emission
then as we are using vending sensitive
fibers and the materials that are using
this new novel cable novel cable Noel
type of cables we are guaranteeing the
future proof of the network making a
more robust and more reliable Optical
infrastructure for the next 25 30 years
to come with this we can reach very an
improvement in the carbon emission and
create a more sustainable Optical
infrastructure in
Europe now I will go through uh the
micro do cables to follow on what
Matthew was saying these are some
examples of how you can maximize the
fiber density in your in in your docks
in your micro dos in this type of this
this is an example of a 432 fiber in
designed for installation in micro dos
with g65 782 200
microfiber it has excellent blowing
performance in 10 mm B micro the cable
is only 8 mm in diameter and it can be
installed in docks with 10 mm diameter
so just a a quick in the estimation of
the field ratio is about 64% so it can
be blown with a very high speed in 10 mm
micro dos that are very common in Europe
then if we look at the total amount of
fiber that can be installed in 50 40 mm
dots we can reach up to 3,24 fiber in a
50 mm dot with seven micro docks
inside if you are using 40 mm 40 outer
33 mm inner docks with the five 10 14 10
or 1210 mm micro do is possible to reach
up to 17 28 fibers and obviously this
the the these cables can be installed as
the demand grows so they don't need to
be installed at at the start of the
project it can be St one one cable today
once that the most of the capacity has
been is operating and has been sold you
can install a second cable and go go go
for increasing the total capacity of the
network this cable was is produced with
200 100 Micron fiber and what happen
when we go with 180 Micron fiber the
density can be increase even more so
this is an example of a cable that is
produced with 200 180 microfiber it has
864 fiber and can be installed in 12 mm
micro the cable OD is 8.9 8.8 8.9
millimeter micro and the field ratio is
about 67% it can be blown in 12 mm 12 mm
micro dos and in a 4033 dot is possible
to reach up to
4,456 Farms so these are some examples
of
what what Optical Innovation is bringing
to high capacity networks you can see
that it's possible to reach extreme high
high count in very small diameter cables
the perform they can be store quite fast
by blowing at the speeds of 50 up to 80
m per
minute this is now we look into the
sustainability obviously When We Make A
reduced diameter cable with reduced
diameter fiber and using clean energy in
Europe that is quite important for
optical fiber manufacturing the
consumption of energy in the fiber
Manufacturing process is very is is a
very energy consuming process so when we
take everything into account fiber
production in in Europe cable production
in Europe and reduction of of raw
materials we can create a
very Green Solution for our customers
for example in this case this is a use
case of one of our customers that in the
past they used to have a micro do cable
with an outer diameter of six .5 mm that
was the standard cable that they were
using and with the new technology with
the new pvt material with the new typ of
fibers we were able to reach 4.5 mm 96
fibers so this is
50% less weight for the cable 50% less
polyethylene for the for the cable when
we go to the microct then the reduction
of potin is more significant because in
the they were using 1410 mm micro dos so
like this one you can see here with the
bigger cable and now they can move to
107 mm micro dos with a smaller cable
here you can see the seven way for
192 version cable so there is a
significant reduction of the weight of
the cable the PO and using the cable and
more space important a significant
reduction of 50% of the poylin using the
micro in terms of civil cost reduction
and installation these type of cables
and micro dos are easier to install
faster to install there is a significant
Cod reduction in the Civil work as you
can imagine like if the micro doct is
50% smaller then there is less digging
less evil
works the micro dos are as as they are
smaller they can be deployed faster the
they they don't have a lot of memory so
you can see here that they lay straight
quite easily without any bending and
this allows for getting speeds of up to
130 m per minute so very fast
installation Speed without a lot of
civil work a significant reduction of
the Civil
work then another benefit when we are
using a smaller cables and a smaller mic
is in the transport and storage as you
can see in this picture here in one drum
we can put the same length of micro do
that we were able to put in with the
previous diameter of micro dos so there
is more length per
drum and therefore there is less waist
less cutting losses when the micro dots
are installed normally in a in a in an
installation there is always uh 1006
between 60 to 100 m or 150 M of micro do
that are wasted per drum so as we have
three drums in one the length of three
drums in only one then there is about 60
to 70% less waste of cutting losses of
the
micro there is less drones that we need
there is less transport and storage
space and less movement L less shipment
to the construction side all of this
reduces the carbon emission of the
deployment based on that we did a
environmental product declaration an
epd for only looking at the cable
without taking into account
the the the installation and the other
contribution to reducing the carbon
emission but we did this based on on a
96 fiber cable it was it was certified
by a external laboratory that is doing
this epd certification and they confirm
that there is a 40% reduction of
CO2 you can see that here that there is
a significant reduction in the CO2
emission due to the polythylene use for
making the
CES then another uh area that we are
looking into as Matthew mentioned is to
use micro do cable micro dos with reward
polyethylene there is less virgin
material and therefore there is less
carbon emission when we use reward
poylin all in all there is a significant
carbon carbon foodprint reduction when
using reward reward polyethylene and
smaller cables and smaller micro and
just to give you an idea 1 kilogram of
polythylene is equivalent to 11 kilos of
CO2 so in a project with 7,000 houses 1
10,000 houses there is a lot of CO2 that
can be saved by using Noel Noel cable
solution and Noel micro do
Solutions another way to maximize the
utilization of the network is to use
overblown systems Matthew already
explained about override of how to
install micro dos in existing docks and
here we is about installing when there
is not enough space to install a micro
doct we can still do an installation of
a cable in the utiliz in the already
utilized
micro so for example we need new cable
system we can put up to 576 fibers in
already occupied 40 mm
dots by doing this there is limited
environmental impa and ER it it can be
reach very high fi count another in
another Innovative way is to use toaca
cables to do river crossing for example
in the north of Europe to cross lakes
and with the new cables that can have
very high fiber count is possible to
have the capacity needed for supporting
the Broadband deployment projects
obviously with this type of cable there
is very limited CO2 emission due to very
little Civil Works
in summary it's important to utilize the
available space to reduce the to the TOC
for this we need Innovative high density
optical cables which reduce diameter
fiber and this way we can support our
customers and the society to create a
more sustainable
less polluting Optical
infrastructure thank you is there any
question
thanks Adrian yeah that's a good point
let me remind you if you have any
questions please post them in the
questionary box and now let me introduce
David Clon area sales manager of Plumas
he will take the last part about uh yeah
upgrade without overbuild and I will
hand over to you
David the floor is
yours thank you very much can you see my
screen
yes
perfect thank you Yan
so yes I'm David I'm a rare sales
manager at PLA and um pra is a company
based in um in Switzerland and uh is a
world leader in cing equipment and
Pioneer of the optical fiber jetting
installation since the 80s
and the goal of my presentation is to
share with you the latest Innovation on
how to install and upgrade um existing
uh in existing
asset so to do
so um my presentation is split into
three section the first is assessing the
existing infrastructure with concrete
examples again is how to optimize it in
a sustainable way through through the
installation of additional micro cable
or preferably as as we mentioned bundle
of
microct and uh the third is how to be
even more
efficient uh and use your resources
wisely while managing your installation
risk with the latest uh digital
service obviously here we have um an
existing asset so low fing ratio quite
inefficient use of resource and a lot of
capacity that can be um that that can be
utilized there is an inadequate fiber
density and we and uh this
infrastructure cannot be uh scaled up so
first when we have this kind of um this
kind of
infrastructure we are aiming to turn it
into a better uh better utilized Network
uh like in the
example and um we can override we can
lay an additional cable we can lay
couple of uh couple of cables or micro
duct uh on top of it but the preferred
um the preferred solution is the jetting
of um bundle of microduct this is uh in
the way the way it's uh it's sustainable
it's because in one installation you can
optimize uh fully your your legacy asset
and the question is how you can achieve
such a result
so Matthew mentioned a couple of
um methodology to uh to deploy it and uh
here I will uh specifically talk about
jetting so for those of for those of you
who are not very familiar with jetting
jetting is a technique used to deploy
optical fiber cable or micro
duct uh via the use of pressurized air
to propel the cable through the duct and
this um this this technique has many
advantages it's uh it's quick it's a
very efficient installation and you
reduce friction during the laying and uh
you navigate through the bands and the
corner much uh much easily than uh than
so you also protect the cables and the
micro duct that you're laying you have
here um an illustration of um of typical
jetting installation so basically the
drum the pushing pushing and jetting
unit and connected to the
duct now to optimize your
asset uh to install an extra cable or an
extra micro duct or a bundle of micro
duct then of course you need uh jetting
machine but you need the Y
connector uh the Y connector in the
slide you see it's a piece of equipment
on the left it's actually connecting and
sealing the existing cable or microduct
depending on your legacy
asset and you and you can um and and uh
uh and this kind of accessory actually
doesn't take much more space nor time to
set it up and in this example we can we
are actually installing you see it
going a bundle of micro duct you can
also install micro one micro cable or
one micro duct but since it's the
preferred solution we are illustrating
with a band microduct so Y connector can
also be tuned and adapted and
configurated uh depending on your cable
existing cable and Al and existing duct
diameter
via VIA a set of
accessories and
then once again because we're focusing
on the jetting of um on the jetting of
bundle of micro duct you use a standard
machine here it is Illustrated
and you can adapt quickly adapt a
kit uh a kit that be configurated based
on the number and the diameter of uh
microduct that you are uh that you are
blowing so basically with
the standard jetting machine in uh less
than half an hour with a Y connector and
the multi duct kit you can actually uh
adapt it and um and uh be ready to
upgrade your uh
asset this is also in terms of
sustainability and resource here it's an
overview of an installation via jetting
of bundle of micro duct uh in this case
it's a 6 time 7 mm uh buannel of micro
that that have been
installed and you can see that except
the additional drum stand uh the rest is
identical uh as a standard cable
installation so basically with uh pretty
much the same equipment slightly
upgraded you uh and the same resource
you can already deploy your your updated
uh asset obviously there is uh no work
for additional Cil work uh no
more of uh of or heavy equipment to to
perform this job so in this sense it's
quite uh quite sustainable it's cost
effective and uh you optimize of course
your legacy and you give it flexibility
for for future
expansion we already uh we already um
gave but um this is an example of fiber
count that you can have in various uh in
various ducts uh depending of the number
of micro duct that you deploy so just
quick just a simple example if you have
one cable that was installed you can
increase it you can increase the the the
the F the fiber count by three five
seven or 10 even more depending on the
on the latest cable that you install so
with the same protective duct you can
have an infrastructure which is up to 10
times
bigger then one way of being sustainable
is also through the efficiency of
reducing the risk of failure during
installation and the third part of this
presentation focus on the digital
service today there are also simulating
tools that allow to manage this risk of
failure um those tools basically worked
uh by importing a trajectory from a g or
just manually generate it um then the
parameters and the equipment can be
easily uploaded onto it or or or or or
or are already preset up and the the
result the feasibility is immediately uh
VIs ible in your office or on
installation site uh those kind of tools
also the digitalization is a very
important uh is a very important step uh
for using more efficient more
efficiently the resource and knowing at
the start of the installation if you can
succeed or not this um obviously uh
uh allows the installer to plan and to
know
immediately uh how much time he needs
and don't have to uh go back and go back
and force on his installation site with
the manyi transport or additional
material by knowing immediately and by
simulating it you also uh do a step in
the sustainability and you're more cost
effective though you can illustrate
basically the fact that the laying is
successful you can see the red line on
top of the screen it's the limit of the
equipment that you've Chen the Blue Line
the curve is the first buildup so as
long as the force buildup doesn't exceed
the limit of the equipment your
installation is successful and then on
the on the below right corner you can
see the duck trajectory that either as I
said was uh imported via VIA GIS or uh
could be actually generated manually in
the system and on the and on the left
part you can see that the result is is
positive because we can uh we can lay
this uh
this Cable in the in uh very um very
well so basically in conclusion today
it's it's difficult to ignor the word
sustainability climate action or the
wise use of the wise use of resources
and by installing additional cable micro
duct or bundle of micro duct via the
jetting method and combining it with a
digital
service uh you can scale up your
existing asset with very with a minimum
amount of
uh was uh this was it for my uh
presentation and if there are
question thank you very much all of you
for this excellent presentations and we
have a couple of minutes
left uh for a few questions and I will
try to bundle some of the questions let
me start with the first question for you
uh
Matthew uh I can see by microduct
overrides are an excellent solution for
D ftth networks but is there any well
else in the network that can be also
useful yes so um I think we focused on
it today because of um full fiber
networks we're going into the densest
part of the networks and so we're most
likely to need to add more capacity in
those dense areas um but yeah the method
itself can really be used anywhere um I
think you saw in some of David's
pictures there um they looked like they
were in rural locations um kind of
backbone networks as well um and jurine
kind of pioneered this method around 20
years ago and kind of over the decades
that we've been doing it we we've saved
millions of uh dollars Euros pounds
whatever for for customers in in various
um locations so examples would be
helping um a customer relocate their
central office out of a downtown area um
to somewhere on the edge of
town um and connect that to the existing
Network um a cross country Railway
Network as well deploying alongside um
in a duck that was deployed alongside a
railway um cutting across the country as
well and then um even really small um
location
like just a busy highway Crossing as
well so that you maybe go a few 100
meters or a few feet um just to prevent
having to add that traffic management
and close a busy Junction as well so um
yeah provided you've got some free space
you can pretty much do it anywhere um
and it's it's pretty low risk as well if
it does fail when when the alternative
is is you're going to have to dig up
again thanks Matthew and now uh some
bundled question from uh from some of
our audience for Adrian which I tried to
put together it was uh is the fin
optical cable more sensitive which I
would fit into the same question with uh
it was asked that the 10880 microns G6
5782 fiber doesn't break more easily
during the preparation of
splicing so the mechanical
characteristics of the fiber d 200 and
180 are quite similar to 250 so they
need to meet the g65 782 standard so the
that Define the the mechanical
characteristics and environmental
characteristics of the fibers as I
mentioned before this is a optimization
of the coating system and the glass to
be able to reach very low attenuation in
cable and still keep the mechanical
relability of the F and when we make
smaller
cables they are these smaller cables are
intended to use in micro and they meet
the I standards for micro do cable that
Define the mechanical characteristics of
the cable itself the crush tension
traction characteristics so all these
cables are designed in the same way as
they were fabricated with
250 regarding the splicing when the when
we splice a fiber the we we need to
remove the de coating and then the the
fiber is fli just because of the glass
the glass diameter is the same for the
three fiber types so they are fully
compatible and they spli as they were
the same fiber so there is more you the
installer need to be used to to to strip
the coating obviously because it's
smaller and you need to have a some
practice but once that they get they
they practice with a few cables then
they are they can do it in the same way
as it was
250 that's our
experience okay thank you uh another
question came in concerning
microing is a 108 fiber optical micro
cable for loose tube design which
exists so sorry can
you uh it's one 8 fiber optic micro
cable for loose tube design 180 Micron
fiber in loose tube
construction no
1,8 fiber optic micro cables in you news
tube 108 fiber micro Cable in news tube
no 108 sorry what we have we have cables
with
1, 720
100 108 I don't think there is something
but this something that can can be
designed for certain type of
constructions yeah
yeah sorry it's not a very common number
108 and then uh once more for you
Matthew can you tell us about any use
case for the new microducts made from
rework
materials yes so the the one that I was
talking about specifically that we've um
developed from our kind of Fallout
material was actually developed in
conjunction with um a fairly prominent
customer in the Netherlands so that they
approached us for a specific solution so
they were kind of ahead of the curve on
these scope three emissions and and
looking for innovative ways to um reduce
those in their Network um so yeah we
worked with them the most important
thing was that it had to perform in
exactly the same way as a standard micro
um and so our quality team our R&D team
sorry worked with them to ensure that it
met the key parameters um in terms of
technical performance out in the field
so two big things were the spiraling of
the duct so the way it lays in the duct
in the the trench sorry and then
obviously the the all important cable
jeton um
performance and um yeah off the back of
that it's it's now installed in live
networks um in Europe as well and we
only really see that the demand growing
for it too so we're actively involved in
in trying to drive standardization on
this kind of product too um so that we
can kind of get a standard language and
um nomenclature and things like that uh
to to Aid customers like that in
calculating the the carbon Footprints
and seeing the the benefits of of these
kind kinds of
products thank you I think we're running
out of time I look at my watch and it's
about uh 3:00
let me just emphasize one more why uh
all our companies uh all our
stakeholders but all our customers are
not only pushed uh from uh you
know pushed in the direction of uh the
different emissions in scope one scope
two of to scope three but uh the point
is soon or later starting for bigger
companies already in
2024 we have a directive from the
European commission which is called CSR
and CSR uh is a directive where all our
yeah stakeholders in Downstream and
Upstream will need to report so we will
be pushed not only from uh our customers
but also from our suppliers but also
from the Regulatory Affairs so with that
let me thank again all our speakers uh
Matthew h
and David for your great presentations
and hopefully I will see all of you at
our next ftth conference which will be
in March in Berlin thank you very much
to our speakers and audience again and
with that I close our session thank
you thank you thank
you